hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast challenges parathyroid hormone
testing in patients with chronic kidney
disease is presented by Ravinder Singh
PhD director of the endocrine laboratory
at the Mayo Clinic in Rochester
Minnesota i'm julie O'Rourke of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen it's like your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or sharing a
presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Singh I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you Judy for the great
introduction and thanks everyone for
joining this online presentation and
topic I'm coming today is the current
state of pts testing in patients with
chronic kidney disease the objectives of
the talk today will be we will talk
about oral history about the PTH test
development and what's the current state
of the PTH SS and what is the latest
contribution of the mass bag method
development for PTH and what are the
various PTH fragments and where is this
development of the normal mer
back meth-head by mass back or other
modalities is going this just slide
reminds that the location of the parotid
gland is imbedded in the thyroid tissue
itself their rarity banks and the
surgeons when they do the better product
mean they are able to locate it by using
radiology techniques and are able to
clear the patient these are the glands
which create better father
how does parathyroid hormone interact
with different analyzing the physiology
and first offered the role of PTH in
defective in the endocrine system air
for example and and we all know vitamin
D is one of the highest ordered tests
these days and a lot of curiosity about
vitamin D but there is a very close
interaction between vitamin D and D th
if the calcium level is low in the human
population that low calcium sent a
signal to the parathyroid gland
it's a pH of our mode which immediately
gets to the bone receptors and resolves
the food in cracks tells you in the
circulation the bth also activates one
of the hydroxyl Azad beginning to
convert 25 to 125 dihydroxy between d
and 125 dihydroxy but even D is the bio
active form of 35 once 125 had lots of
vitamin D is available in Physiology it
acts on the receptors and the god of the
inter sign level and helps in absorbing
the minerals especially calcium in
phosphorus back into the human
circulation and it helps in depositing
back into the bones the next slide here
shows the complexity of the same what we
deviate endocrine system and now in this
have almond in the center of the diagram
there told this is critical for the
whole physiology of maintaining calcium
and formation of vitamin D which is the
active form of vitamin D what is the
clinical utility committee chair since
it helped in differential diagnosis of
hypercalcemia it helps in the diagnosis
of hypo and of terrorism and as well
hyperparathyroidism and in the category
of light will be for ambience they have
apparent medicine and the third will be
diagnosing menial also dystrophy and
improving patient management in
monitoring disease patients since this
is a very complex disease physicians
have various algorithms and this monitor
algorithms published by the National
Building Foundation in case of secondary
hypericin
how to use bphs there's we can see here
in patients with a reduced GFR there
will be reduced Commission of 125 and
then in fact of the PDF speech 10 and
those issues will fall in the category
of the second hyperbaric medicine and
they will have the loss of the bone
quality and leachable all this option
here are the guidelines for the SI que
te moana bill intensity and kind of
defines what are the targets levels for
serum calcium phosphorus to be geared in
a patient population who is affected by
renal disease or locally function all
the defining any disease the calcium
should be eliminated him eight point
five and has been - it's the same as the
reference range for the normal healthy
people phosphate 0.55 for time and the
calcium phosphate product should be less
than 55 in the appendix of the intact ET
age normally in the health of which
could be the rimmel
but it is recommended that in patients
with the stage
or state 5 chronic kidney disease idiot
values can be as high as 110 or 300 ml
in stage by patients and that may be the
normal level for patients who have
chronic kidney disease the purpose of
this slide showing here is that calcium
is critical for making the diagnosis of
these patients whether they have
hypercalcemia or not and in our
laboratories we are very proud of the
quality of the calcium test him because
all the couching tests by all
manufacturers and vendors are very well
standardized in trustingly the normal
values are also variable standardized
they go from a 25 to 10.2 in all the
hospitals in the lab and clinically if
the doctors will take a action if the
value drops by more than 0.4 or 0.3 7
milligrams per year and the CLIA
accepted the performance which is the
gap also accepting performance will be
within plus minus one milligram per DL
to pass the quality of the test among
various labs I'm going to review some of
the Kapoor College of American
Pathologists
data for the PTH essays from Dave's
survey as recent as 2018
this slide shows that how many labs are
performing a particular benefactor asses
as you can see it here out of 1500 labs
there are 500 labs which are performing
those cars si and then the second one
because 400 labs are performing Siemens
APs and the rest we can look at yourself
that we have many many manufactures in
the field who make various s is the
difficult as have chosen to go the
different practice based upon their own
experience and the qualities of the
assays how does the data look like when
the gap survey gets sent out the lab the
lab returned their values
all the data which they have received
back for the 2008 things away and the
cab shipped out three samples where they
all met me in the blue color is the with
the value of one twenty seven point
seven five the red one is three hundred
and ninety point five three in the green
one is thirty three point seven six so
if all the methods were standardized
very well and we should have seen that
all they would have reported the same
values but I will show you in the next
slide how do these results vary from one
to each other this slide is highlighting
the deceiving of PSA dozen crease for
the green sample which as a lower mean
value compared to the booth sample which
is a higher of the red value so the
Seabees are in general lower to the
higher values but they're slightly
higher for the low all method mean value
and some manufacturers have a CV in the
range of 15 percent or higher and the
some manufacturers are performing close
to five percent and as we know as a
laboratory and the lower the CV the
batter is the assay but interestingly
the main fractures who have ghosty be
for the highest samples like you and
bring in but their CB is higher for the
particular if that low value sample and
this particular slide is showing that
how to DSS differ in their values if
they all methods were similar to each
other
then we would have seen all blue green
and red bars and a hundred percent of
each other what you're saying here is
that different manufactures have a
different biases from the all method
move sound as a reporting goal where it
is especially for the green sample which
is all endogenous yet well knew the
other two samples the red and the blue
values a spike the 124th
which are closed
the reality or all that mean so this is
a highlight how it is challenging that
the labs are not using the essence which
are very well standardized so one
hospital may be using one acid when the
patient moves to the end of the lab they
will have to read on the desk to get
their bit as a baseline before and after
the surgery because the energy is a
different manufacturers
phtt want you to determine if the
surgery is successful or not let's go
back to the history of parathormone as
you can see this is a citation from 1973
there was a conference held at Mayo
Clinic and I worked at the Mayo Clinic
and Lorna investigators got together and
they discussed about how to develop
liquid air support parathyroid hormone
what is this role and then these
investigators have published an article
to highlight the challenges of EPA
testing and it's complex role in the
challenges in 1971 word that we did not
had enough amount of the air to inject
the animals to raise the antibodies so
that was one of the largest challenge
and both times was to synthesize PPA to
the recombinant form for the PDA tract
which as well and the other challenge
was there were new technical
methodologies which allowed to look at
all the various fragments into the human
serum or the plasma because the
concentration of B is PPA jyeo PPA tract
result very long this line highlights
the half-life of various PTH fragments
we get one twenty-fourth of supply
intact and is active is half-life is
five minutes P and n terminal fragments
also are bioactive half-life is similar
five minutes the idiot with a little
back wins don't have any buyer activity
and their half-life is much larger than
24 hours and the C terminal fragments
which lack in two
which they also have very long half-life
but their activity is controversial or
is not well known then as you can see
here that the c-terminal flag means
building issues with the chronic kidney
disease and they can reach as high as 99
to 90 to 95 percent of the total feed
yet mass in those patients it's just two
highlights
we have tabulated what are the various
possibilities fragments reported in
various tables as you can see the edges
are very active molecule and it
expletive alized in table circulation
and it is circulating in multiple
fragments and that is the Challenger
support varies as is the how many of
these factors have picked up when
assesses and how many of these penguins
are clinically relevant and that is what
we are learning as we speak the purpose
of this line is as you can see
highlighted in green red hair on my
right-hand side of the slide that the
levels of pdh are much much lower than
the levels of hemoglobin and albumin by
a few orders of magnitude the lower the
concentration for the PTH the most
challenging and difficult is to perform
a test upon the Lord the analytes like
other cytokines neutral thickness will
have a similar challenge to that harm
one because they're trying to find a
needle in the haystack
which the contact ologies not there that
we can pick them very specifically and
very sensitive matter
the other challenge for the PTH testing
is that the pink th hormone gets
modified and this light highlights some
of the fine lines can get oxidized and
that will change yet if you idiot as
well and we will have to know where is
the video and politician in what kind of
epitope that would respond
bodies and if you're developing that
deals with respect test are you looking
for an oxidizer of today's won the Nobel
Prize for developing amino acids for
various proteins or peptides like pH and
instant land was given to the proposal
yellow and she was successful in raising
antibodies against insulin and developed
her very good si and in those days we
had a competitive radioimmunoassay and
dr. Rosen yellow walls were working to
mobilize put that great contribution to
other science in the lab that is the
area because we have been thinking about
it yet since 1970s now we have three
generations of the asses we had all
competitive radio amino acids then we
replaced the radioactivity with the
chemiluminescence of horses as attack
and then we call them second-generation
asses the other improvement we made was
that we made those as a sandwich asses
which held us in improving our
sensitivity and specificity and the
dynamic range of the assets and now
recently some companies have tried to
make an S which is very specific to the
course of you may know assets of the
n-terminal and they are categorized as
third-generation Fiat assets this
particular slide highlights the sequence
of the ETH harmonious receive onto
several amino acids very essential for
the ETH activity and this helps in
designing and understanding various as
if somebody says C Double L ETH acid
that means the antibodies go target it
with words on my right-hand side which
is the PPA if someone stays intact a
state that has an intact or a whole
molecule by having an antibody one
towards in terminal 2 terminal and the
third generation is still the same as
the second generation except their one
antibodies all
more specifically the fossil fuel
minimizes then the second generation
yesterday which may not be becomes
possible to most people in assets but
definitely this towards the end terminal
region of the ETH this slide highlights
that different manufacturers have
targeted entity bodies again tip reports
the Vth ETH has a three dimensional
structure and radius animals to respond
differently and then you have the
supreme various and what is it do that
which antibody you would like to use for
your asset remember basic background
here are two the the PTH asses work as
you can see here this is a comparative
amino acids in comparative analysis we
can use only one anybody nearly seven
three had only one anybody's even that
was a blessing at one antibody all those
animals at that time Google using PD
edge and then we will using labored
mediate is a competition that able to be
redirected to feminine distance but now
we have moved to the sandwich assays
where we can have one anybody gives the
n-terminus acne antibody against the
c-terminal and make a very good
percentage and this way of the response
is also linear compared in comparing
verses where the response is inversely
proportional to the signal so there are
many many advantages of the sandwich
asses and also using a signal which is
in a chemical sense for choruses
compared to the radioactive signal
this slide shows that how the sandy
Jessica's performed and how the Evolve
EPA testing is picked up as they intact
molecule and then all the fragments will
not be picked up because the and both
antibodies have to find the pH at the
signal but if one anybody binds to an
terminal get immersed in terminal but
that won't make a great entry will not
see the signal so this signal is only if
the bridge is formed by using intact
idiot
in the beginning of the antibodies was
raised and we also raised over all
anybody's at their clinic in the forms
there we injected one boards using the
internal peptide the other go to the sea
to look up tide and then we purified two
different loans from the antibodies and
we mobilized one everybody this is a
sequel to the B and then the other
antibody was labeled to be active
investor to do the same once a stay is
developed and validated and so far we in
1992 there was a lab developed asked
about Mayo Clinic and we were very
fortunate that assay was able to supply
patients from family had terrorism most
of the patients were secondly there is a
slightly overlap but definitely was able
to separate patients who have deep
hypercalcemia to billing Minsky as
proceed on the x-axis wrong color with
the red dots there and now it is a lot
of effort trying to standardize we have
many many many lectures who may care
since they are trying to sterilize by
choosing the common calibration of the
fire lip-reader
and be purchased from the w-h-o World
Health Organization and it helps in
using the calibrator by different
manufacturers and hopefully we all go to
the same results and here is the
highlight a paper was published in 2018
and this is where they describe that the
person will not be able see and two asks
for the same interactions but
unfortunately if you look at the data
here whether you look at the zooming in
to zero two hundred people per ml or all
images either the constant on besides
choosing the World Health Organisation
calibrator there is no optimization
ideally all of these lines should be in
the top of each other but one thousand
is giving us typical values when you
spiked the pho
and it would make like some try to read
into various as this as sales of
different colors and different
manufactures ABCD the black have been
practice closer to accuracy versus other
manufactures are giving much higher
values so there are multiple papers
showing up out there that how do we
compare between different manufactures
even though there are differences over
slopes the calibrators proper a
correlation and unfortunately the
correlation is also not very acceptable
these are the blend and in part which
are highlighting differences between
Alexis and liaison ideally all the dots
should be closer to the line you have
the constant eyes but at least you can
predict that what kind of price you will
have one si but then you have fire
spread out as is and it is very hard to
predict what is the correlation between
two the glasses and as you can see here
the slope of years those between
different ranges are different here and
very talented and unfortunately a common
practice to agree with each other and
all these manufacturers have shown that
none of their essays have any
interference so what's the difference
between second and third generation
idiot asses as you can see here there is
a si called cyclic GMP they appear to be
DHS in interactivity HSA and cyclic a
and is considered as it gives us more
values and then the interactive edges is
assigned values and then little
diagnostic also at the two S's which
they are separating or 124 goes from the
other fragments but what you can see
here is that when we have
autism and overlap the controls the
analytical specificity may be better in
one way to grasses but clinical
proponents of the two S's is not an
indifferent only the numbers are lower
in 124 or the third generation asses
compared to the second generation desmos
let's get back to one of the questions
we asked in the beginning because of the
challenges we have with the various PD
HS is the PTR test results we produced
all in patients were falling 50 disease
I don't think I will be able to provide
that answer to Emily and answer to your
own judgment we can't defend you used to
widen like I represent for PT agency
education is very wide for example in
the two to nine times of the healthy
population and clinicians are not
supposed to simplification staff or
surgery as long as the value is to be to
at 9:05 as you can imagine that is a
very very big lead and it's not very
helpful that because we may be business
and agency but we would have benefited
surgery and taken care of and s it has
been proposed in the literature by
different that first in the field that
may be liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry that it may be the Canon
ef-s birthday and providing light is to
harmonize and standardize various PKS is
and we jumped on this wagon and in 1908
and then intend to publish to this paper
wonderful my paragraph awake both on it
and we developed a of schemas and this
page and similar method was also
published by Mary in the past
group at that time and how people was
also published in the same issue as you
can see it here these were very
uncomfortable papers and we had a great
collaboration of the two groups and we
hope that this did help getting some
clarity about problems with the various
universities publishing district papers
are likely allow you to walk through
some of the data we collected during
those times when we published papers we
were verifying pdh from the human serum
by choosing one of the commercial
antibodies which helped us filming PDF
of idiot pregnancies remember who was
using only one antibodies which won't
see the middle-sized pill felt pick up
184 as with a satomura fragments then we
digest it and random a chaplain aspect
as with a smooth down here and in the
calligraphy we got multiple practice
times here we did try without digestion
but our sensitivity was not as low as we
needed for the patient here so we had
reduced to digestion not my choice but
that was of the meat at the same time
our workflow is highlighted in this line
here that we will incubate this bead
which in bowling to a 96-well plate and
then add human skin which is one amount
that we had labeled 15 th as an internal
standard behave debates for four hours
at room temperature and we want to get
rid of all the interferences because the
pthe defined the beads and every other
PDF protein
then we adjust it here in anything else
bound to antibodies and then we take
those supernatant and injected a spam
this just highlights that molecular
weight of the intact
age and when you trips and eyes it does
has a cleavage ad position about
thirteen and that was in fact when we
were monitoring as a surrogate of one 24
2013 be pH was a surrogate for
contradict or PDF and then the second
fragment we added in Kiruna that we
start with tell nanny that game which
will be a surrogate for some 280 40 th
and this thing says the same thing here
in a linear PDF version manner as you
can see we will be quantifying 1 to 13
mm s I guess it because the digestive
side at there these are the mass spec
transitions for the old analyte already
6.22 6:35 whirlpool and NTP
would be full 98 point you to 643 saying
that we will have number of amino acids
which have labeled within 50 and we want
one in pink particle charged species
here and that's the reason our cue
benign is 490 2013 it is the to charge
business this plot shows and bidding
against the you know seven six and nine
is correlation
this slide shows those two things from
each other
- 13 7 to 13 and this is what you get
for a patient in the presence of matrix
business the signal to know is that when
people go and we can see because seeing
more than will be boys this is one of
the drawbacks when we compared our data
from those PDS to respect appeared to
solve is never acceptable College in
testing
the demon made the comparison with you
boy it looks acceptable in this figure
but if you play an organ that you start
seeing difference is much larger than
clinically some patients will have as
high as 40 personal values by one method
and then lowered by the other Patrick so
we do have and we still can't say which
where there is a gold standard because
the aspects still needs a lot of work
this just further highlights here that
this workflow is also the voice for the
mass spec so people have tried to
replicate this work and we are thinking
that different aspects have gotten
better in 2018 and we look for the
intact proteins and peptides digest them
so this is a work done by the CDC's and
for Disease Control under the leadership
of dr. Hubert Westberg they just started
this project and they're looking for in
tact proteins and they're very hopeful
that they can see down to 10 mm and this
is radius that in women s back intact
124 V th and this one is the past action
for 124 in the presence of internal
senate pain very good quality
perspective obtained by CDC this is the
highlighting that you can really
separate very easily and 15 labor pH
from then still the difference between
the two weddings previously us being
looking for the intact PTH was attempted
by Lopez's probe by using MALDI approach
MALDI is not as sensitive as
electrospray but they were able to see
not only one to any four but they were
able to see many of the fragments also
in renal failure patients and non
attempts are being made between mail and
CDC that can be look at the fragments
which were observed by the multi and we
see the electorate this is very ugly
work preliminary work where we are
excited to see that some of these
fragments are observed in patients with
the aim of innovations one thing which I
would like to clarify and this being
this a lot of people talk about some
grading for para para harm on existing
lead in circulation this participation
which was led by dr. table and the data
will do his own data and the data form
of Lopez's group that we have no
indication that 784 exist in human
circulation so we need to start off
white using the 784 is one of the PD
edge metabolites we have not seen itself
and now we're excited that because it is
e and we are working together to do
developing best practices not only 120
bps back then but we are going to look
for many many other fragments and as you
can see in the slide fragments which are
highlighted as being were observed in
males validate all these fragments in
collaboration with CBC and see what are
their relative concentrations in various
patients consider this as a preliminary
work here on the slide here there are
various fragments which interpretations
of the conical disease from the control
disease patients this is reproducible
then in addition to the motivated for
introduce other
PTH fragments which will help us in
improving the page air or the tonic any
disease the PTH s is do have a
reputation that they don't compare where
each other again 2018 but in 2003
a message I understand all that India
and not only that having a consistent
passed a similar manufacturer was also a
problem and that was at least and one of
the reasons that Nicole Institute
diagnostic had stopped making this essay
and is not available to market and it's
been an impact of having various asses
in the market depends for his years in
classified duplications in two different
categories occasions where that they
need some kind of drug treatment over
surgery and if you notice here by
juicing because Allegro area at one time
we had 13 patients in pH range of
complete hundred then we have 11
patients range of he under two five nine
nine but defined on the same group of
patients by using the livers advantage
and I would have 1714 and three versus
disc antibodies as they will still give
me 13 so anybody agate intact has is
matching with the mucosal lagrua in
massive it does not match the egg masses
and the old as well intact as they only
picked up three patients in this
category in the last as they had 18
versus 11 instances one so different
patients will get different feedbacks
based upon what else is used which is
very very concerning and not a good
patient care because we have differences
in various Fiat assets so as you can see
highlighted here in this slide here we
have different different grouping based
upon pH values particular assets what
are the causes for different values we
kept on differences the differences can
be because every factor is using
different capture of label and worry
every actualizing
standardization against the elevators
and again the matrix also is genes
differently to make the controls and
elevators and each manufacturers have
different information times also the
quality of the essence so in summary the
management of patients with the conical
indices all the mineral density is very
complex and monitoring pp8 value will
remain part of the practice because
today we don't have good imaging or the
coal fires because they're very
expensive and laborious so H infinity
but the value added additional care
could be if we could harmonize various
winners a testicle in practice and the
quest here is the defenders football to
the CDC us developers portal to the USA
it's known as if you all got a positive
impact I would like to talk and thank
you for to speak to me every day
questions
Thank You dr. Singh for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email let's get started
the first question is why is it hard to
standardized parathyroid hormone assays
thanks Judy it's a very good question
and I think in my second last slide or
you know I try to highlight here and I
think this may explain some of the
reasons but there could be more and more
reasons and because of the competition
we have among the manufacturers among
the commercial labs everybody's using
different recipes and we don't have a
consistent supply of the calibrator
consistent supply of the reagents and
all this is adding up to have a
different recipes for different asses
and I think that could be one of the
major reasons for causing this
variability and it will be hard to
sterilize asses until all the
stakeholders sit down and meet and talk
about it next one is what is the role of
parathyroid hormone fragments again
million dollar question here I think we
are learning as we speak the fragments
have been known even though but we don't
know whether they are our active or not
so there are experiments being carried
out what are their concentrations in
patients with continued disease we
didn't never had a good method to
monitor those fragments and now we will
for the first time in coming few years
we will have a meth
the way we can look at the concentration
the fragments and then some physicians
will have to do or some researchers will
have to inject those fragments into
animals or patients and determine
whether they are by active or not but
either way it will help the community
that we should thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question is a mass spec assay better
than an immunoassay yeah again a tough
one question it depends do you ask
and people think I will say mass spec is
better than the amino acid but I mean if
we were only looking for a patient
population where the CKD disease patient
population was not in the patient care
pool
so for primary hyperparathyroidism I
think amino acids are perfectly fine
even though they differ from each other
as long as the hospital keeps on running
the patient before and after the surgery
or before after the treatment and
physicians are aware of that the mass
spec s is part is the most random but
they come with a baggage this is a very
expensive laborious technology and
implementing and replacing all the amino
acids will not be practicality we just
need to come up thank you
like to once again thank dr. Singh for
his presentation we'd also like to thank
lab routes for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February 15
2019 you will receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast would be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye
all righty perfect you did a wonderful
job very nicely done okay yeah so what I
will do it this point is I'm final
touches on the recording and get
everything set to be broadcast over
those live dates from this week and just
again as a reminder because we did pre
record everything you will not have to
be available over those live dates if
you are up for responding to any
questions that are submitted they would
just get sent right to whatever email
address you would like them to be sent
to and then at your leisure you can
respond to any questions via email okay
perfect
and then the last kind of housekeeping
question that I have on my end before we
go today is would you like to make your
sides available for the audience to
download in PDF format definitely not
something that you have to do but we do
like to offer that if that's something
you're interested in
sure okay perfect I will make a note of
that on this end and did you have any
final questions for me on your side
before we go today well I'm good thanks
for your time and thanks Judy wonderful
thing thank you yeah thank you so much
Drucker saying I know you're very busy
so we do really appreciate you taking
the time out of your schedule to do this
and if you do think of anything after we
go here today please don't hesitate to
reach out wonderful thank you so much
and enjoy the rest of your day thanks
you too booth all right have a good
night